we have the story from the post
millennial Tucker Carlson reveals
producer who called Biden a wannabe
dictator was punished by Fox News and
resigned 24 hours later good for you
dude good for you standing up
just days it for Fox News displayed and
then apologized for a Chiron calling
bite in a wannabe dictator Tucker
Carlson slammed his former employer
actually I I think legally current I
don't know is Tucker saying he was fired
anyway they're going to mention the
Chiron wannabe dictator Fox's statement
saying the the words were up for less
than 30 seconds inside Fox the women who
run the network panicked Carlson said
they first scolded the producer who put
the banner on the screen and then less
than a day later he resigned he had been
at Fox for more than a decade he was
considered one of the most capable
people in the building he offered to
stay for the customary two weeks but Fox
told him to clear out his desk and leave
immediately the company then issued a
public apology for the Chiron that was
on the screen for less than 30 seconds
stating the Chiron was taken down
immediately adding that the issue was
addressed that was all true but it was
not enough to save Fox News from the
ensuing Scandal for a time and the rest
of the media Fox's assessment of Donald
Trump's arrest seemed to overshadow
Trump's arrest itself said Carlson
Carlson noted perennial MSNBC guest in
full-time Ukraine promoter Alexander
vinman who called for Fox News to be
banned uh called for Fox News be banned
on all military bases it was a really
great Point brought up by Tucker Carlson
because all of the lies from CNN and
MSNBC and uh where was he to say that
those networks should be banned from
military bases as well but uh I have an
idea
I'm gonna put uh I'm gonna give a shout
out to daily wire put that on the spot a
little bit and we'll put Tim cast on the
spot a little bit
let's see how many of the Fox News
employees we can hire
the ones that don't want to work there
that don't agree with them that actually
care about American values reject the
lies and the manipulations and uh I say
the daily wire in fact I'm not really
putting on the spot I think the daily
wives start poaching Fox employs right
now just start hitting them up and uh
we'll do the same you know we'll uh if
you're if you're leaving Fox News you
don't want to work there anymore because
they're full of it because they're lying
we do not here at timcast have any kind
of Dei advocacy programs or requirements
or anything like that and uh
so yeah there you go opportunity awaits
yeah I think it's important one thing's
gonna be hiring some uh look I mean if
artists want to reach out to us who are
making uh animation that's decent and
who we could bring onto our team yeah
we're expanding so so uh hit me up if
you're like an artist if you're a
cartoonist who's qualified to animate
please send us a message and also if
you're someone who wants to support the
team that we have who are artists
creating non-wo content create a
conservative content please become a
member at freedomtunes.com it helps us
to keep everybody employed but I I want
to mention here is that when Tucker was
first pushed out of fox I was cautiously
optimistic and I knew that he was going
to be fine but I was a little bit
worried because as I mentioned earlier
Fox tells conservatives what they're
allowed to believe and having somebody
like Tucker pushed out of the network
means that that Overton window shifts
back to the left a little bit and so I
was concerned by that but
I'm glad to see that fox which is
effectively controlled opposition is
starting to show its cracks and the
response to it is very decentralized if
you didn't like what the mainstream
media was saying for a very long time
Fox was your only option at least for
visual media if that's how you were
consuming news nowadays you have so many
different options it's wonderful there
are so many different podcasters and
journalists online who are delivering
information to the people from their own
angle whether they're just not far left
whether they're you know a more
traditional liberal a conservative
someone who's further to the right you
have a lot of different people who are
not all under one umbrella giving us
information that we never would have had
if it was just up to Fox I got an idea
here's what we at timcast will do we
will make mandatory employee training
yes and it will say things like have you
considered having a Fourth of July
barbecue and perhaps grilling and having
a nice non-bud light beer have you
considered reaching out to your friends
and explaining why America is the
greatest country on Earth perhaps you
should fly an American flag on your
property that's what we'll do I think we
need to train out the implicit
anti-white racist bias and everyone who
gets hired we need to have presentations
and stuff to to sort of brainwash them
yeah yeah
if you hire them from one of these
organizations you have to do it it's a
notoriously racist organization this is
against white people it got to deprogram
them it is something funny that I've
thought about there are people who
worked for uh Vice and BuzzFeed and I've
tweeted like I'm so sorry to hear you're
getting laid off you know we're hiring
and we're expanding and looking for
people so feel free to reach out they
never do of course but like what's gonna
happen when there's no game in town
anymore when you're when you're like a
buzzfeed Rider with no skills they're
going to be voting for communism because
the only thing they can do is write
nonsense listicles and other fake news
all they can do is write the fake
article they were told to write
but what are they going to do there's
going to be nowhere to work they're
going to go to Academia that's where
everyone who you know fails in politics
goes I just think yeah but like that's
the only thing
but then College bubble bursts right
because that's a very real possibility
especially with money getting tighter if
we see a massive economic crash I mean
some of the first degrees
he'll keep that up forever of course I
know he'll be able to
be able to do it forever I'm not being
entirely unserious I mean even with
even a Colorado sound article that we're
talking about with uh this reference
that journalist is quoting a study where
he's like and look a professor at a
university said it's true I mean these
relationships between journalism and
Academia could be really powerful and
strong could be a great way to get new
information out there it just so often
both sources are corrupt and therefore
release terrible information that then
the public is supposed to consume
without questioning well you know
totalitarian regimes always need their
academic sounding lackeys so in that
sense you'll always have the university
system as it stands for as long as the
regime continues to exist however every
single individual person being pushed
through it I don't know that that's
going to be sustainable in fact I know
it's not going to be sustainable it's a
question of how many sacrifices this
system is going to force itself to make
in order to continue it because it's a
very valuable tool right not only do you
have 12 years of government
indoctrination but you throw another
four years on top of that where people
are being given and even more vicious
and depraved version of the same
far-left ideology that kids are set up
to believe in their first 12 years of
education and you end up with a very uh
High flute and academic sounding surfs
so it's it's a valuable venture to them
but I really think at some point they're
just not going to be able to afford it
and then there will be less
professorships available money is not a
real thing though I mean we just give no
huge loans from I mean what is it 94 of
all student loans are from the federal
government that we then give to people
to go into debt to then say we need more
government to solve the problems I am
now facing because I'm massively in debt
and theoretically overqualified for jobs
I don't really want anyways which is
causing me depression which is causing
me loneliness like we are pushing people
to a cliff I don't see me specifically I
don't think anyone in this room but the
system that is currently in place pushes
people towards a cliff that makes them
desperate and makes them compliant the
amount of government money also pushing
Academia that will hire all these folks
as government funds to do these study so
that University of Colorado study
probably got a fifty thousand dollar
Grant from the Department of whatever at
the Colorado State House and and it just
creates this cycle I mean 1.6 trillion
dollars had to go to something well no I
was just going to say the National
Bureau of economic research has said
this before that universities respond to
the widened availability of easy money
and more people being able to get loans
by raising their prices so the whole
thing does feed itself but at the same
time those dollars even though they can
print as many of them as they want they
represent real world resources and the
more the economy contracts the more
difficult things get the harder it's
going to be for them to sustain it I
think we do want to see cities die I you
know you know I thought about this and
now I think no yeah you know we probably
should
because we were talking about it last
night in terms of how do you teach kids
hard work and I know you know this down
because you're a farmer and you've got
animals and uh I was telling the story
where we had someone I was showing
someone the property and we've got
insane fruit I've got mulberries there's
probably 700 000 mulberries just within
like a couple hundred feet it's Bonkers
you look at this tree it's just food for
days yeah you're not gonna you know
survive on just mulberries but there's
uh Allegheny Blackberry there's apples
there's pears there's walnuts we got paw
paws there's just food growing
everywhere that we want it to or not
and it's interesting that people who
grow up in cities don't experience that
I certainly did we had a a pair oh no we
had a plum and a Cherry Tree when I was
a little kid and so it's like oh yeah
food grows but people who live in these
cities are attached to these
corporations they don't know how to
survive without having a boss pay them
money and that was one of the that was
always something really crazy to me
when people would say stuff like I need
a job and I'd be like no I need to make
money like where is this disconnect
there were people in my life who would
be like I'm having a hard time because I
can't find a job and I said okay well
then go do a thing to make money but
they don't know how they don't they
don't these humans have never
experienced doing things on your own
they they lived in a house where the
food was just there they got old enough
they got a job the boss gave them the
money for in exchange for the work and
then when they lost that job said well
now what
for me my mentality was always you don't
need a job you need to convince someone
legally to exchange the money in their
hands for to your hands like you need
someone to have money in their hand to
go like this and then you take and say
thank you now figure out the safe legal
and moral way to make that happen and
that is you can trade stuff you can you
can perform I was I was busking in the
street you can do fundraising whatever
yeah but people in these cities have
become weird mechanized laborers
and their only their existence can all
it can they only exist to work for
someone else and that's in my opinion a
very serious problem and it's probably
if you look at the school system and how
it's just basically churning out workers
with this uh factory-like system where
the bell rings and everything I think
that may be it so you know what leaving
orange non-workers maybe now yeah maybe
we just need these cities to actually
fall apart so that people are forced to
re-align themselves with the world and
then actually start for one realizing if
you want food you have to work well I
think you can make the food there's a
huge problem I think with the younger uh
you young people with the younger
generation that the vast majority of
them for a living want to be
tick-tockers or YouTubers and not that
we would ever make fun of YouTubers
right who would do things on online I
think they're idiots I'm a journalist
but you have to admit like what you are
all bringing to the table is a certain
skill set that people say it's worth my
two hours right now because the value I
am getting for that is greater than and
it's not a a money exchange although
there are members of timcast.com
um but it is a Time exchange
um I don't think a lot of young people
see well what is the skill I am bringing
it's like well I want the fame I want
the notoriety I want the I want the
clicks yeah I want the viewers but what
is the skill you are bringing to the
platform whether it's tick tock whether
it's YouTube whatever it is or are you
are you showing people how to lift
weights are you giving people an idea of
how to think about the world it's like
no I just I just want to be a YouTuber
well I think that's the bad thing this
is where uh the effective Decades of
reality television are starting to set
in right people think I want the fame I
want the clicks on the notoriety I want
the attention and I want people to want
to know what I'm doing and saying and so
they exchange their privacy for uh
attention online I mean so many
influencers are actually just kind of
very serious open uh bloggers right
they'll tell you everything almost like
they'll show you the pictures of their
houses they'll show you the inside
outside their kids crying like and if
this is the way you want to live your
life I'm personally not comfortable
doing that but it does eventually for a
lot of people turn into their own
reality new TV show that then brands are
like oh we notice a lot of people like
you so we'll give you money and they're
able to cultivate a business off of
selling their privacy they don't sell a
skill they sell themselves well so this
idea of people becoming decadent and
lazy in cities dying eventually it's
certainly not a new one and it makes
sense right because the family is the
the building block of society and we see
families follow this trend when a family
becomes extremely wealthy usually within
a few Generations that wealth is gone
because you had a patriarch of the
family Who Rose up from nothing and was
able to develop a fortune for his
descendants and perhaps his sons build
upon that and they accumulate an even
greater Fortune but at some point they
end up having so much
to the point where they're not as
concerned with The Economic Consequences
of not putting in the hard work that
needs to be put in to maintain that kind
of a fortune they become lazy and
decadent they start spending that money
without sufficiently adding to it and
within two or three generations it's all
gone and I believe there are studies
that actually show within about three
generations most family fortunes
dissipate so we shouldn't be shocked to
see that happen on a larger scale with
these cities many of them were extremely
wealthy at one point but what happened
was the people became complacent they
became lazy they became more concerned
with consuming then producing and that's
why they're falling apart we are just
seeing the dissipation of
intergenerational wealth on a broad
scale
the Rockefeller Grand
great-grandchildren are the ones who are
probably my age maybe a little bit
younger older Etc
um so John D I think one of the greatest
Americans in the history of of our of
our nation right Standard Oil
um wealthiest man in the history of the
world by far way wealthier than Gates
and and and in proportion to the society
and to uh percent of GDP just just you
can't fathom the amount of money
um but his Grand his great-grandchildren
now are the one who are disowning him
climate change activists we we are
ashamed of our great grandfather his
legacy whatever money's left it's like
well you're going to give it up yeah
it's like you're so embarrassed give it
up like go get a job go flip Burgers
it's like well no like I want like what
great grandpa left to be like don't get
me wrong like I'm ashamed of it but I'm
not gonna go be like you people it
always makes me laugh and you know
there's I'm not the biggest fan of
Rockefeller but the reality is he saved
the whales right if we if we weren't
using oil people still would have been
hunting whales and they would have
hunted them to Extinction it's true he
saved the man any credit for it never
yeah the original Greenpeace activist
exactly but no but this is the thing he
saved it by producing something instead
of shouting at people yeah so then that
can't be celebrated now there's a
thought make things yeah thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time